yesterday the CDC unanimously
recommended approval of the vaccine uh
for 5 to 11 year olds
um I did not understand that there was a
uh a hidden incentive for that that
would actually give the adult vaccines
um immunity as do I understand that
correctly yes
that is shocking I did know of the prior
story where the emergency use authorized
vaccine retained its uh liability
and that a person who after the vaccine
was given authorization
um not authorization given approval
a person who went in and got the
authorized but not approved vile even
though in theory they contained The
Identical uh substances of different
labels they had different labels but a
person who got vaccinated wouldn't even
know what they were vaccinated with and
therefore wouldn't understand that they
were actually being vaccinated with
something that gave the manufacturer
immunity from liability even though the
FDA had signed off on it at that point
so these games are everywhere and I will
say the the most common theme throughout
all of this seems to be accounting
Shenanigans right the label on the
bottle affects your ability to Sue or
not to sue somebody who dies
um with covid is presumed to have died
of covid a person who has been
vaccinated but hasn't been two weeks out
from their vaccine is treated as
unvaccinated all of these things are
used to create a story that is not true
um but in any case yesterday the CDC
unanimous recommendation for the 5 to 11
year olds to be vaccinated
I can see exactly zero medical
justification for this as you point out
healthy children do exceedingly well
with covet it's not a dangerous disease
to them what's more
plus like a lifetime immunity to get
lifetime immunity so from the point of
view of a very Rama robust and broad
spectrum community that is going to
protect them against all variants and
unlike the vaccine immunity which is a
very narrow spectrum and which requires
and boosters year after year after year
and those boosters each come with a risk
of Adverse Events so from the point of
view of the medical well-being of a
child this is a very strange it's very
clear that it is damaging that you're
going to cause far more problems or
injuries than you're going to avert
and you know but the uh it seems also
clear that the rationale is economic
rather than a public health rationale
well I agree with you I also the more I
think about it the more this does feel
like a modern Tuskegee
a Tuskegee without race because
effectively these children are not in a
position to consent right just as
participants in the Tuskegee experiment
were not informed right they were told
they were going to get free health care
and they did not understand what what it
was that they were being signed up for
and what harm they might come to
this is effectively that with no medical
justification
we are apparently going to push vaccines
towards children who would be better off
if they got the disease out of the way
I mean we I want to be careful in saying
that because there is we do not know
that 20 years down the road from a
coveted infection that it is not going
to re-emerge and some harm come from it
but based on what we do know about covid
the harm to young healthy children is
absolutely minimal and that means that
the Adverse Events that children will
face if they are vaccinated are
uncompensated and they also you know
there's really strong indications for
example
you have the story of Maddie Gary oh we
know it's one of third they're they're
going to give this the 26 million kids
and they only tested it on 1300.
and one of the 1300 we know at least one
of them
is spending their life in a wheelchair
with a feeding tube and that's just the
beginning of madagari's suffering
because her life is now
a nightmare of agony
uh um so
what we have to assume you know if we if
we look at the reason we have clinical
trials
is to look at the risk
um if you give it to the entire
population so if there's a one in 1300
risk
of ending up in a wheelchair for life
with a feeding tube
I you have to extrapolate that out to 26
million people and you may be able to do
that in your head but I think it's like
20 to 35
000 kids who might who potentially are
now going to be exposed to that risk and
uh you know that's a much much higher
risk
than there is from that we know of from
covet well we have to leave open the
possibility that Maddie Gary was very
very very unlucky well yeah but here's
the thing
under federal law
the any injury that occurs during a
clinical trial must be attributed to the
intervention and so they legally The
Regulators and the company
must legally assume that that is a 1 in
1300 risk that's going to apply across
the population right that should be that
should be the presumption and then it
could be demonstrated that it was just a
fluke but of course short of that
demonstration we have to assume that
that's that's the Baseline but you know
if you're only going to test your
intervention on 1300 people before you
give it to 26 million you ought to be
stuck yes with whatever the outcome is
especially these these I mean I must
tell you the the recommendation to
vaccinate young children
for this shocks me more than anything
I've seen so far and I've been
repeatedly shocked but this is
so
Brazen and so indifferent to the
suffering of people who
cannot know better cannot presumably say
no
it
it's inconceivable to me that
um
let's put it this way as an evolutionary
biologist I almost never use the term
evil because I believe you almost never
see evil it's a terrible strategy right
it a morality is a good strategy you see
that regularly
sociopathy is a good strategy yeah it's
it's an immorality but this is so
um yeah
so Brazen and the harm will come to
literal innocence that I I don't think
there's another term
I really do think that this is uh
um
this is an atrocity in the making and uh
I don't know what we do about it but I
do think maybe maybe because the
evidence is so clear that children
healthy children do not suffer serious
harms from covet itself and because even
the broken Vare system captures this
huge signal for Adverse Events including
depths from these vaccines that many
people who have gone along with the
public health narrative so far
will detect that something is wrong
something must be wrong for us to be
dragging our children into this when
frankly they are a population that just
doesn't need this protection now what I
suspect is that in many of these
people's minds there's a conflation
between the well-being of the individual
and the control of the pandemic and
although I think it is an appalling
argument one could make a rational
argument for vaccinating children to
control the spread of the disease of
course these vaccines are not effective
at controlling spread but nonetheless
that might be on some people's minds but
even that
what healthy Society
transfers
hell risks from from
children how do you justify putting a
children at rest in order to
preserve in order to protect old people
um you know listen
this is always this is like a baseline
philosophy 101
um you know uh a dilemma exercise and it
always has the same outcome as you don't
you know a government
cannot put one person at risk to save
somebody else you know you know that's
just something that we understand and
Western
liberal democracies and in western
civilization that you don't do that
and yet
um and not only is it other people but
it's kids
[Music]
foreign